Check out this week's must see movies!
"How's it going?"
*Window Smash*
"I won't be followed."
Tom Cruise is running from the law in the action flick, "Jack Reacher: Never Go Back".
"When I find you, I'm going to kill you all."
"Hi! We're the Joneses."
"Who are these people?"
These neighbors are not what they seem in the action comedy, "Keeping Up With The Joneses".
"The Joneses, they are not who they say they are..."
"Woh woh woh, WAIT!"
"I'll show you..."
"Are you here?"
A little girl is accidentally possessed in the horror thriller, "Ouija 2: Origin Of Evil".
"Do you know what it feels like to be strangled to death?"
*Mumbled Screaming*
Let's check out this week's Fanticipation.
So what's your weekend ticket going to be?
Let us know by commenting below, see ya next time on Weekend Ticket!